I'm gonna solve three massive business
problems that gonna take you from 10 to
100 million dollars and at the end I'm
going to walk you through the framework
so that you can apply this to your
business your work or your personal
brand I recently spoke an event it had a
q a section and there were three
different business owners that presented
with different problems one was an
employment setting business and they
knew how to set appointments and build
outbound teams for agencies coaches
Consultants whatever the second business
was a marketing agency for HVAC business
owners the third was actually a very big
influencer 30 to 40 million subscribers
across all platforms with the objective
of making more money so each of them had
very differently phrased questions but
they were all suffering from the same
constraint and it wasn't what they
thought it was so the first business
that asked a question was an employment
setting business and he was saying that
his problem was that he needed to get
more customers which by the way most the
time that's not the problem it's usually
because the customers you have keep
leaving and that's the real problem and
when we look at businesses to invest in
at acquisition.com we operate off of a
singular concept which is the theory of
constraints a business will grow up to
its constraint and then it will grow no
longer most entrepreneurs continue to
work on the things that they enjoy
rather than the things that the business
needs usually because they haven't
actually identified the correct
constraint for example if you have a
three-step sales process and you get 50
to go through step one five percent to
go through step two and then fifty
percent to go through step three you
could improve each of them by ten
percent but which of them makes the
biggest difference in your business
going from 5 to 15 triples the business
whereas the other ones only
incrementally improve it by twenty
percent he had a very low quality of
customers the vast majority of customers
didn't make enough money they didn't
stay long enough they didn't have enough
skills Etc that was what he thought he
had to solve he said okay of all of the
companies that you've ever worked with
which of them made the most money off of
the appointments that you set right and
you had a very specific answer of what
type of Avatar he did best with and so
there's two directions for that business
one is you Niche down on your service
delivery and say these are the only
types of businesses I'm going to take
because they're going to be worth more
stay longer referrer Etc that is
probably the easy easiest next step for
that business if I were gonna own this
business and I transplanted my brain and
my experience with his body that he
could own half of a 50 to 100 million
dollar business that he grows over the
next five to ten years picking the most
valuable business that he sets
appointments for what would the
marketing spend be of a business that's
doing 50 million dollars a year
realistically probably somewhere in the
neighbor of five to ten million dollars
a year so he could either partner with
that business or spend a year or two
learning how that business works so that
then he owns both sides of it if you
partner you can usually go faster but
you give up some of the upside because
you slice the pie it's up to you because
most business owners the reason they
don't create valuable businesses is
because they have to keep doing the same
work over and over again and they don't
get credit for it basically sentenced to
this terrible atlas-like existence of
rolling the boulder up the hill and then
rolling it back down every every month
but if the team that he built was 50
outbound guys this month and then next
month he starts at 50 because it's all
within the same company and then does
another 50 and then another 50 D six
months later he's got 300 outbound guys
that are all still working for him all
generating Revenue that he is owning a
slice of all of it business number two
was the HVAC agency this is a business
that markets for HVAC companies 850 or
so clients in that Niche and their
running campaigns across 50 different
local markets if he's able to generate
leads and fill up 50 different HVAC
Services pipelines because of his
marketing prowess he probably has the
marketing skill of a 50 to 100 million
dollar HVAC business if you have a five
million dollar marketing agency then
it's reasonable that some of the clients
that you serve are making 50 million
dollars in Revenue off the services
you're generating and you're getting
none of that you're only capturing the
service fee the more steps you take
towards owning the result the more
you're basically just doing the business
for them but at a certain point you are
the business and so it makes sense for
you to own the economics of the business
either you've got to learn the HVAC
business or you partner with some
someone who already knows it or you
could buy one and with your marketing
prowess you juice the hell out of it
most people will try and buy it but then
also try and keep this agency thing
going but sometimes you got to take a
half step back so you can take 20 steps
forward the fastest way to build a 10
million dollar business is often not the
fastest way to build a hundred million
dollar business if you wanted to build a
building that was 10 stories tall you
would start with a very different
Foundation now imagine you built a 10
story building and then said okay I want
to build 100 story building using the
same Foundation you wouldn't be able to
but that's exactly what most
entrepreneurs do when they're trying to
scale and they wonder why they're stuck
is because they built it wrong to begin
with because they were in the wrong
opportunity vehicle one of the big
things that took me too long to learn
was it's the size of the slice of the
pie that matters not the shape of the
slice of the pie they obsess about the
shape of the slice rather than having a
slice that's like this of a much bigger
pie the average IPO founder when
accompanying IPOs owns 12 and a half
percent of the company they found it
because the more people you make money
the more money you also we make the
third business was the big influencer
business dude 30 40 million subscribers
across all the platforms and they were
focusing all of their attention on how
do we get more high quality videos out
and when I asked them what problem are
you trying to solve they said we want to
make more money you're seeing your
business as this box of media and trying
to make more better videos which if you
want to do brand and just continue to
build a brand before making us that
would be the right problem to solve but
they were at 97 out of 100. they're a
point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent Creator so do we really think
that they're constraint of their
business is that they aren't good enough
at marketing no probably not you guys
are trying to take your 97 out of 100
Media company to a 99 out of 100 Media
Company when the objective you said was
to make more money and you have no
product that you sell so all of your
monetization relies on sponsorships and
AD and AD Revenue which is typically the
least efficient way to monetize because
anyone who pays you for a sponsorship is
making a huge Arbitrage on your brand
and your value given the amount of
Impressions that these guys were getting
which when they don't make videos we're
getting 100 million views a month when
they don't post anything new that kind
of thing is a company that's 100 million
plus in Revenue so they have the
marketing department but what they don't
have is a sales department they don't
have a product department they don't
have customer success they have none of
these other departments they're 0 out of
100 on all these and so the constraint
isn't going 97 to 99 it's going from
zero to twenty on these ones what are
the choices I have here version one is
if I've got an average consistently
comes to me I may be able to negotiate
some sort of equity getting even 10 of a
company that's worth 100 million dollars
and then you put all of your effort
behind it and make it a two or three
hundred million dollar company that's a
significantly better outcome for many of
them than what they're currently getting
paid just video to paycheck right the
second option is to say okay is there a
category of products that continue to
pay me the most out of all the
advertisers just do what Amazon does see
what's already selling and then clone it
and make it your own and put your name
on it and make your version yours and
better if you do that then you own the
entirety of that thing but in order to
do that you probably if it were me I
would go snipe some of the topics act
that some of those companies and say hey
you're currently an executive here would
you like to own a slice of my thing I'm
happy to own 70 and get three of the
best guys over have them build their
boxes behind my thing that's the fastest
and easiest way the longer maybe bigger
money way is if you do it all yourself
but that's always the trade that you
have to make as an entrepreneurs how
many new skills do I have to to have in
order to pursue this new opportunity
versus the ones I currently have the
third opportunity for them is probably
the least operational risk for accepting
the fact that they just like doing media
and that's what they jam on and they
don't want to touch either these other
business components ending themselves as
a creative shop that knows how to make
viral videos that they can transform
into ads and that's where you go from
being a really good Creator to being a
Madison Avenue agency that makes ads
that Crush most influencers are getting
paid based on the Impressions that they
are getting the brand for free based on
their audience but where the real money
is made is where you take that Tick Tock
video that YouTube short that Instagram
video that number it is and then they
put a million dollars of AD spend behind
it when it's already shown as a winner
and then it goes from being shown to 5
million people in your audience to a
hundred million people that it converts
from cold ad spend has no limit on reach
as long as it's profitable so they can
always expand beyond your existing
audience which means that you get to
capture all of the upside based on how
skilled you are as an Advertiser so
those would be the three paths for that
particular type of business it's not
like okay well I'm not one of these
three businesses now what I should do
but it's actually the framework that we
approach the problem with which is one
what problem are we trying to solve in
each of these businesses they wanted to
make more money the next one is over
what time Horizon if you want to make
more money tomorrow the number of things
you can do is very limited if you want
to make more money in 10 years you take
a very different play if the amount of
time it might take to build 100 story
buildings Foundation might take the same
time it takes to build the entirety of a
10-floor building above the surface
somebody else building a 10-floor
building might happen way faster than
you because as yours is just continuing
to build this base before you start
building up the next question which
problem would we prefer solving or which
problem do we feel like we're more
equipped to solve or which problem is
easier because if you start framing it
in terms of the problem that you're
gonna have to solve to be successful it
actually makes it much more controllable
for you I would say well which of these
do we feel more equipped to do now at
acquisitions.com we are really good at
recruiting which is how we scale all the
companies we have recruit Talent we've
already been there done that and so we'd
probably say hey we feel really
confident that we could recruit somebody
in and put seed capital in to get it
going then we'd own the whole pie so for
us that would be a problem that we feel
very confident in solving and gives us
the most upside you have to answer that
for you given your skill set your
resources and your experience